alors en france sachez qu on est autour
de 98 voilà la moyenne elle est au tour
de sang voilà 98 toi là il aurait donc
accueilli près de deux fois supérieur à
la moyenne
alors je vous dis est ce que nous on a
calculé votre client vous a demandé
faire un meeting à oui j'ai les
résultats isabelle l'a pas fait mais ça
ne s'est pas ça non mais c'est pas grave
on s'en fout mais ensuite on ne l'est
pas mais je ne vous arrive pas les
lignes se confondent au goût de mourir
pour moi donc ça m'a fait chier la
troisième question là on vous à vous
avez trois de cuivre c'est le chiffre
que j'ai là alors on a ensuite en numéro
1 celle qui a le plus gros qi de
l'émission ils sont deux égalités gilles
verdez 127 et géraldine maillet 125 en
numéro 3 le plus gros qi de tp mpc
nicolas pernikoff ah bon ça va
et tous fait un petit test après midi
oui oui c'est les vrais chiffres qu'on y
donne suite au numéro 4 6 valider
mailing avec avandia guillaume genton a
central 103 de cui cie les autres
comment ça va un petit peu sac et son
téléphone la gare est pas très bien non
parce que j'entends encore un téléphone
sonne et ça va jouer il va prendre dans
la gueule comme chez moi c'est vrai
c'est moi alors les chéris ensuite à 102
cuit il reste delphine et benjamins
il y aura ou une qui a eu 50 ha merde la
moyenne vous avez dit la moyenne des
français c'est 98 98 à dire que c'est
une personne car presque la moitié de la
moitié de l'ensemble des français
tarascon a soumis à tous les chroniques
[Rires]
c'est le vrai test 1 c'est le jeu vous
dire
ça se joue entre delphine et benjamin
delphine ça va ça va il s'est bien passé
à fort boyard
j'ai chanté avec dave j'ai réalisé un de
mes rêves donné peut-être un indice
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors castaldi ça va très bien c'est
juste une petite question vous avez reçu
ce test par mail oui
ceci explique peut-être cela non pas aux
mêmes visuels celui qui a 58 depuis ses
bas ça m'agace et bien sûr el tri des
jeunes gens bien
bassam à vous a vu 58 de qi mais il ya
de plus intéressant c'est toi vous êtes
tout en haut
cette fois tout en bas donc j'ai un peu
raide mais souvent la même place j'ai
répondu à jo un peu à peu rapidement
c'est quelqu'un qui arrive que ça c'est
un client de chèvre et on aimerait matin
quand huit c'est vraiment ces genres une
chef qui suivaient pas ajouté
voilà ça c'est valable pour vous mais
pas pour moi mais non non c'est très
très bien en tout cas voilà au réveil on
a fait l'état tu as fait ton cul ical ou
pas j'ai abandonné
moi je vais arrêter non non vous avez un
très bon niveau on aurait des surprises
jamais une chose mais attention ça n'a
rien à voir avec la ceinture c'est la
lose est la logique
mais c'est parce que c'est un garçon
intelligent ah ouais mais nice est très
sexy au modelage avec mariama vous avez
souvent vu vous avez souvent que des
hommes qui ne sont pas particulièrement
avec de très jolies femmes par exemple
pas regarder et ils sont pas forcément
fortune expérience et l'intelligence
peut rendre vraiment être stoppé sa
voiture souvent riche quand même quand
les mecs intelligents et qui n'ont
annoncé pas voilà c'est pas l'heure
c'est ma maman quand j'ai vu dès qu'on
allait avec con comme une pendule très
riches s'est pas vu des mecs très
intelligent et vous voit sa main sur moi
mon mari fait partie des 5 % des gens
une plus intelligent dans le monde sait
les tests j'ai lu tout à fait
officiellement levé
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ça se voit pas toujours d'accord
gilles verdez n'ont pas fait ce qu'on
veut ça je rallume c'est important pour
vous un garçon intelligent
bah oui mais benjamin pour moi être est
un témoin aussi je veux dire la vérité
lecture des images je vous jure que
c'est vrai avant il va se taisent
j'étais persuadé que c'était moi j'en
rêvais
parce que pour moi si je veux manger
j'ai fait les ags de série b répondu je
préviens pas d'accord c'est pour être
dernier à eauze c'était une blague
d'accord il ya la télévision spectacle
show away donner quelque chose parce que
je vous avais la première partie non non
non